-4 squared, with parentheses, is 16.
That's because -4 squared,
with parentheses is the same
thing as -4 times -4.
The base is -4.
The negatives cancel each other out,
and we're left with a positive answer.
-4 squared without parentheses is
the same thing as -1 times 4 squared,
which is the same thing as -1
times 4 times 4, which is -16.
-2 to the fourth,
with an exponent, gives 16.
That's because -2 to
the fourth with parentheses is
the same thing as -2 times
-2 times -2 times -2.
There are an even number of
negative signs being multiplied, so
they cancel each other out, and
I'm left with a positive answer, 16.
-2 to the fourth is -16, because -2 to
the fourth without
parentheses is effectively,
-1 times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2.
The base is positive 2.
And what I'm left with is -16.
-3 cubed is -27.
That's because -3 cubed is -1 times 3
times 3 times 3 which is -27.
Remember that if a negative sign is to
be included in the base of an exponent,
the base including the negative
sign should be in parentheses.